nous sommes en direct avec joseph
moukarzel député suppléant des français
de l'étranger bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france c'est un verdict
qu'attendent les libanais en dépit de la
crise multiple qu'ils traversent enneigé
on a tendu les ampoules avoir des
limites cervélo et il était même le côté
de quelques jours rappellent à la grande
explosion qui a dévasté berry
dernièrement le 4 août
donc c'est vraiment débile que tous les
libanais attendent certains avaient
beaucoup d'inquiétude doute veulent
vraiment tourné la page
le tribunal spécial pour le liban s'est
penché sur les liens entre les accusés
ou manche ites boulakia déjà annoncé
qu'il ne reconnaîtra pas le verdict
comment interpréter cette imposition du
hezbollah tout à fait légitime il ne
peut pas se permettre que nous avoir
assassiné ou d'être accusé d'avoir
assassiné le premier ministre van eck et
sunnites dans des régions où les
tensions entre sunnites et chiites sont
assez tendus et les grappes même
aboutissent dans un suivi en irak et
dans le reste des régions comme les mn
et cetera des guerres quand même assez
important
donc le réseau là
nommé par milk homme accusé d'avoir
assassiné le premier ministre unis de
l'ue vivant et grâce qu'on peut
s'attendre à ce que ce verdict bouscule
un peu plus encore le liban est ce qu'il
risque d'accentuer les tensions dont
vous parliez à l'instant entre sunnites
et chiites dans un pays déjà sous
intentions écoutez déjà ce que la
déclaration du chef les réseaux la
racine à cela et essaye un peu de
minimiser la chose du point de vu si
nombreux
aussi dès que le tribunal n'est pas
juste qu'il a il va accuser pour des
raisons politiques rivaux l'un de
l'autre tu es le fils de radis lille
l'ancien ministre libanais saad hariri a
déjà déclaré que son que son père est
mort pour sauver le liban parcours de
détruire donc il a déjà donné ses
directives à nos gens qui osent unique
qui dans nos bâtisses à la vue de ne pas
du tout faire des réactions mais on peut
s'attendre dans d'autres factions
sunnites qui ne sont pas avec ça traduit
à des réactions un peu plus violente
demandant pour autant que le sandre
hariri soit
nous a pas versé comme ça pour rien donc
on s'attend quand même à une montée de
tension au liban
je doute qu'il y ait qu on en arrive à
la russie dans quelques escarmouches
dans quelques quartiers limitrophes
à mon avis ça savent être là mais une
tension de plus ajoutent à la tension
existante dans un pays qui n'a pas de
gouvernement actuellement
saad hariri puisque vous le citez qui
affirme par ailleurs que ce verdict
attendu sera un jour de vérité de
justice pour le liban est ce ainsi qu'il
faut interpréter ce verdict qui se tient
en l'absence des quatre accusés jugés
par contumace côté le jugement par
contumace est un jugement
donc ce que disent a pris la route
il est temps de glo de clore ce dossier
de savoir qui a des gens qui ont été
accusés qui ont été jugés quand même
dans d'asile dans un autre il attaque
très violente qui a tué beaucoup de gens
avec avec ça avec le fils cadet rire et
même dans tout beyrouth donc c'est
justice doit être faite peut-être les
gens ne vont pas prêt il n'existe plus
on pas là mais le jugement a été arrêté
et c'est très important aussi d'avoir un
jugement d'avoir vraiment quelque chose
qui nient qu'ils arrêtent ce tribunal
c'est un moment en accusant certaines
personnes donnent citant certaines
personnes comme étant celles qui ont
fixé est atteint
attendre en quelques mots qu'elle trace
à l'essai cet attentat dans la vie
politique libanaise
écoutez on parle aujourd'hui du 4 août
comme étant vraiment un cataclysme
je pense que ce qui a précédé avant la
mort de la faire car il était aussi un
cataclysme politique parce que ce
monsieur avait l'envergure très grand
régional
à tel point qu'on
on a dit que c'est pas il n'a pas été
tué à cause de la fatigue premier
ministre où qu'il soit partie prenante
au liban d'ailleurs il faut souligner
que la ferrari composé très bien avec la
red bull à l'époque
donc ce n'est pas vraiment ça qui
peut-être faut-il mettre les choses dans
un cadre beaucoup plus grand peut-être
qu'il y avait il avait une mission qu'il
a fait tout ça c'est des hypothèses
savez en tant qu'analyste ont fait
beaucoup d'hypothèses mais en tous les
cas aujourd'hui
la mort de ce type en 2005 a changé la
face du web en quelques pages est
aujourd'hui dans la fin du tribunal
l'enfer l'arrêt que le tribunal va
donner aujourd'hui va aussi le chlore
une phase compenser minutes parce que
c'est une autre de conflit un nouveau
conflit je ne pense pas parce que confie
le conflit est là tant il est toujours
là mais je suis sûr que certains
profiteront de la chose pour mettre une
tension de plus et quand je dis certains
je pense à des des forces régionales et
à des forces locales sur place au liban
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions de si bon matin
joseph m15 elle je rappelle que vous
êtes à député suppléant des français
d'étrangers